[Musique]
lorena
tu m'a abandonné ouaddou j'ai abandonné
tout le monde je suis là pour le boulot
tu serais sur une enquête criminelle
alastair pinch il a tué sa femme les
studios ne pas reconduit ils veulent
mettre un détective sur le court c'est
bon on laisse moi te faire revenir à la
civilisation
monsieur waldau
cette histoire de meurtre a boosté les
audiences je pourrais négocier 6
millions l'épisode mais il nous faudrait
100 épisodes et alastair pilote doit
être heureux en forme et à l'abri de la
peine de mort le texte je voudrais vous
présenter charlie waldau le détective
dont on vous a parlé
allez vous aviez non pas du tout
blanchir les médias vont adorer me voir
en robe de chambre il est peut-être
armée rouge alastair pinch je vous
arrête pour le meurtre de monique à
finale s'il vous plaît pitt on est
obligé de faire tout ce cirque il te
revoir à votre joli manoir laurence
olivier
[Musique]
le monde entier crois que j'ai tué ma
femme monsieur waldau et je peux même
pas vous dire si la région
vous voyez ce trophée c'est un prix
d'interprétation qu'alastair a eu en
angleterre vous l'avez déjà vu
c'est la vraie arme du crime
maternelle des enfants de célébrités
monsieur le lion voudrais demander à
mademoiselle white si papa joue aussi
bien avec les autres enfants le modèle
white et j'ai besoin qu'on continue de
parler génie mme baars et soir j e
client qui a du mal à saisir pourquoi
vous vous êtes associé avec un ouvrier
comme alastair pinch
monsieur white au laissez moi vous faire
un avis
vont peut-être confiance
[Musique]
vous voyez que vous auriez pu inviter
quelqu'un et avoir oublier l'enjeu ce
soir un gage enfants aux emprunts
immobiliers je n'ai jamais rien oublié
de tous challandes
faites gaffe
c'est sa première semaine en dise est
bien arrivé souvent surtout après la
pause déjeuner la princesse je me suis
mouillé pour vous sauver la vie venez
mon ami d'accord on va tu t'occupes pas
d'alastair pitch
[Musique]
j'ai passé un agréable moment